Free Speech Warrior Elon Musk sues to
stifle freedom of speech again uh Elon
Musk filed his thermonuclear defamation
lawsuit against Media Matters after the
media Watchdog reported that
advertisements could appear next to
racist or offensive tweets the problem
is he forgot to sue for defamation but
that's just the tip of the iceberg of
legal problems in his latest anti-free
speech lawsuit I did not see that coming
yes when Elon Musk purchased Twitter in
2022 he met with representatives of
several civil rights groups to discuss
how the company would do content
moderation going forward musk had vowed
to make Twitter a Bastion of free speech
and that had made many people nervous
that he would allow banned accounts to
resume posting musk promised to start a
Content moderation Council to determine
what happened to Bann users however he
didn't form the council so the civil
rights groups called on companies to
pause their advertising on Twitter
corporations like General Mills and
Volkswagen stopped their advertisements
musk blamed the Jewish Anti-Defamation
League for a $22 million drop in ad
Revenue he then gave General amnesty to
suspend ended Twitter accounts and fired
most of the employees who were tasked
with monitoring hate speech he also
dissolved the trust and Safety Council
that had been formed in 2016 when the
ADL reported that hate speech had
increased on the platform musk said it
was a lie and that hate speech
Impressions were down he promised that
the at safety account would begin
sharing data but the account only shared
the data once in March of 2023 the at
safety account said that the company was
defining hate speech more narrowly by
evaluating slurs in the nuanced context
of their use now whether it's hate
speech or offensive speech the First
Amendment projects hate speech from
government censorship but private actors
like Elon Musk and corporations can make
their own decisions about what they want
to say that has nothing to do with the
First Amendment so as the owner of
Twitter which is now X but I'm still
going to call it Twitter musk has a
right to post any opinion he wants ban
or unban any users and promote offensive
content and also individuals and
corporations and advertisers have a
right to participate on the platform or
not so in May the ADL published a report
about the rise in anti-semitic hate
speech on the platform the group pointed
out out the obvious that by taking away
the moderation guard rails more horrible
things were being shared in June musk
hired Linda yino as the new CEO now she
doesn't have all the powers of a normal
CEO but one of her roles was to make
good with advertisers musk threatened to
sue the ADL but later made nice with the
group instead he decided to sue a
different media Watchdog group The ccdh
and at the same time Elon never stopped
promoting conspiracy theories which
brings us to November 15th 2023 when
musk boosted a post that said Jewish
people have been pushing the exact kind
of dialog iCal hatred against whites
that they claim to want people to stop
using against them uh this was a
reference to uh the white genocide or
replacement theory in anti-semitic
delusion that suggests Jews are
promoting immigration same-sex marriage
interracial marriage and pornography and
other things in order to destroy the
white race musk appear to agree with a
post about white replacement Theory
replying you have said the actual truth
this interaction prompted some
advertisers to flee Twitter at least
temporarily and on the heels of this
event the liberal advocacy group Media
Matters then released a report showing
that postc containing pro-nazi content
appeared on Twitter alongside of
advertisements from leading companies as
part of the study the company created
new Twitter accounts and apparently
curated the interests of those accounts
the company report alleged that quote
advertisements have also been appearing
on Pro Hitler Holocaust denial white
nationalist Pro violence and Neo-Nazi
accounts Media Matters found ads for
Apple Bravo Oracle Xfinity and IBM next
to posts that tout Hitler and his Nazi
party on X you can see screenshots of
these posts here at this point I
consider displaying the ads in question
but honestly it's just really sad and I
don't want to promote these ads even in
this particular context uh just trust me
they're not great in one of the ads a
user sad because Nazis aren't running
the world um that appears next to an
Apple ad another tweet is talking about
how the Third Reich was good actually
and that appears next to an advert for
Xfinity Bravo and Oracle share space
with a user who believes the Holocaust
never happened uh and as we'll see in
the lawsuit musk doesn't deny that the
ads appeared only that the Media Matters
account accounts had a very unusual set
of interest that led to a rare
algorithmic feed now that report put
Media Matters in musk's crosshairs he
alleged the real reason advertisers fled
was the Media Matters report rather than
his own post professing agreement with
all of this horribleness in reality both
events probably played a role and he
promised to file a thermonuclear lawsuit
against Media Matters the second that
Court opened of course these days uh you
can file electronically especially in
federal court you actually don't have to
wait until the courthouse opens and
shortly thereafter musk promoted a
pizzagate meme so anyway uh the
thermonuclear lawsuit against Media
Matters is now here and uh yeah it is
the slapp slap suit that you can
possibly imagine now we'll talk about
the allegations in a second but right
off the bat this is not a defamation
suit uh some legal commentators who
should know better really think that it
is a defamation suit uh they are really
confident in asserting it's a defamation
suit and they are very wrong about that
this particular person is wrong about a
lot of things but while this lawsuit
repeatedly mentions defam it does not
include a defamation claim instead there
is a cause of action for a tort called
business disparagement which is similar
to defamation but in the business
context with some key differences now
the torts of defamation and business
disparagement are similar and that they
both involve harm from the publication
of false information but they're
different in the interest that they seek
to protect in the way that they do it
defamation serves to protect one's
interest in character reputation whereas
business disparagement protects economic
interest by providing a remedy for
pecuniary losses from slurs affecting
the marketability of goods and services
elements of business dispar M are more
stent than those of defamation because
business disparagement protects against
pecuniary losses so the publication of a
disparaging statement concerning the
product of another is actionable when
the statement is false published with
malice with the intent that the
publication cause pecuniary loss or the
reasonable recognition that it will and
pecuniary losses do in fact result now
the actual malice standard does apply
because the plaintiff here is a public
figure and merely showing ill will or
intent to interfere with the plaintiff's
economic interest is not sufficient to
establish malice so like defamation
Abyss disparagement to defendant may
only be held liable if the defendant
knew of the falsity or acted with
Reckless disregard concerning it or if
he or she acted with ill will or
intended to interfere in the economic
interest of the plaintiff in an
unprivileged fashion and as always a
showing of truth of an allegedly
defamatory statement negates the element
of falsity for a business disparagement
claim so what are the allegations
against Media Matters and its reporter
well the lawsuit alleges that Media
Matters systematically manipulated the
Twitter experience in order to defame
Twitter now as always a complaint is a
one-sided document that simply
represents the story of the plaintiff so
it's no guarantee that it's accurate but
here the complaint says quote on
November 16th 2023 Media Matters
published a false defamatory and
misleading article with the headline X
has been placing ads for Apple Bravo IBM
Oracle and XFinity next to pro-nazi
content claiming that X was responsible
for anti-semitic content being paired
with x's advertisers paid post this
statement was not true and Media Matters
knew it as explained below and displayed
played in an X internal review this
title is false in that Media Matters
itself not X was responsible for
placement of the content and identified
through its willful exploitation of x's
user features a result it's specifically
intended to bring about X in fact has
many default safeguards that prevent the
platform from displaying content in the
manner artificially achieved by
defendant so the Crux of this claim is
that Media Matters created Twitter
accounts and Then followed Fringe
accounts with the expectation that
eventually offensive content would
appear next to the ads in other words
Twitter didn't deliberately Place
advertising next to offensive content
Media Matters created the conditions
that caused the ads to appear quote
Media Matters did not find pairings that
X passively allowed on the platform
Media Matters created the pairings in
secrecy to manufacture the harmful
perception that X is at best an
incompetent content moderator a harmful
accusation for any social media platform
or even worse that X was somehow
indifferent or even encouraging to Nazi
and racist Ideology Now other than the
legal conclusions and certain adjectives
that are being used here I actually
don't think that Media Matters would
disagree with the facts as laid out in
this allegation it's true that Media
Matters created the conditions for the
pairings to appear by using the platform
as it is permitted to be used by
following accounts the user is
interested it the complaint says that
Media Matters Ed the platform in a way
the platform is able to be used but that
it did so with bad intentions quote Next
Media matter set its account to follow
only 30 users far less than the average
number of accounts followed by a typical
active user 219 severely limiting the
amount and type of content featured on
its feed all these users were either
already known for posting controversial
content or were accounts for X's
advertisers that is 100% of the accounts
Media Matters followed were either
Fringe accounts or were accounts for
National large brands in all this
functioned as an attempt to flood the
Media Matters account with content only
from National Brands INF Fringe figures
tricking the algorithm into thinking
Media Matters wanted to view both
hateful content and content from large
advertisers now this comment about
tricking the algorithm is interesting
now metaphysically I'm not sure that
there is a thing that can be done to
trick trick in algorithm um I'm not sure
that that's a thing that exists in the
universe but Twitter admits that users
followed by Media Matters are known to
post controversial content the beef here
is that what Media Matters did is
inauthentic and inorganic but of course
because Elon Musk or as some people are
calling him now space Karen uh because
he pushed back uh that has caused lots
and lots of other people to go digging
for other examples and as Mike maznik
has pointed out they found them a lot of
them uh so many of them now lots of
Twitter users are reporting that they
found offensive content next to ads as
the Daily Dot pointed out a bunch of
users started looking around and found
that ads were being served next to the
tag H Hitler and kill Jews among other
Neo-Nazi content and accounts and it
seems these users didn't engage in any
of the manipulative or inorganic actions
that execuse Media Matters of using they
just followed vile hashtags and found
monetized content so the complaint
continued but this activity still was
not enough to create the pairings of
advertisements and content that Media
Matters aim to produce Media Matters
therefore resorted to endlessly
scrolling and refreshing its
unrepresentative hand selected feed
generating between 13 and 15 times more
advertisements per hour than viewed by
the average xuser repeating this
inauthentic activity until it finally
received Pages containing the result it
wanted controversial content next to X's
largest advertisers paid posts but it
appears that Media Matters did not
falsely report on the content that was
found on the platform it reported what
it saw after it created the accounts but
it's not surprising to find racist or
anti-semitic content on social media
platforms even with aggressive
moderation some post will still get
through but Elon Musk and Twitter seem
to be claiming that it's not fair for
Media Matters to draw attention to these
racist needles in the Hy stack it
doesn't seem like that satisfies the
standard for making a false statement
now Ela mus claims to be a champion of
Free Speech but of course he filed a
lawsuit to stifle the free speech of
Media Matters claiming that they have
disparaged the company by using the site
in an inorganic Way by repeatedly
scrolling and refreshing until they saw
what they'd HED to find quote Media
Matters generated a specific intended
result that was not only inorganic but
exceedingly and demonstrably rare all
while taking specific steps to obscure
this in a November 16th 2023 article the
overall effect on advertisers and users
was to create the false and misleading
perception that these types of pairings
were common widespread and alarming
Media Matters hid its manipulations
through omissions deceptive image
selections misrepresentations and
secrecy settings musk says that Twitter
safety measures quote under normal
organic conditions operate seamlessly
contradicting seemingly every single
Twitter user's daily experience now as a
a viewer of legal eagle you're probably
not only very smart and very
good-looking and you've probably already
spotted the problem with Twitter's
claims here it admits that what Media
Matters reported was actually true
Twitter calls the Confluence events that
led to the advertising context rare and
inorganic but rare and inorganic is not
the same as false it's actually more
like the opposite of false and as far as
I can tell Media Matters never made any
claims about the frequency with which
advertisers advertisements appear
alongside offensive content and as Mike
maznik Tech put it quote Media Matters
never made any such Claim about how
frequently such ads showed up and as IBM
noted in pulling its ads it wants a zero
tolerance policy on its ads showing up
next to Nazi content meaning that even
if it's true that only Media Matters
employees saw that content that's still
won too many people uh you might
remember Mike as the guy that coined the
term the strian effect I wonder if that
term applies here now the other two
claims in this lawsuit are for
interference with contract and
interference with prospective economic
Advantage now to Prevail on a claim for
torous interference with a business
relationship in Texas a plaintiff must
show that the defendant intentionally
prevented the formation of the business
relationship or contract and that's not
easy to prove a plaintiff must establish
that there's a reasonable probability
that the participating parties would
have finalized an agreement or business
relationship but for the meddling of the
the defendant and crucially the
plaintiff also has to show some sort of
willful and intentional independently
torous Act of interference that caused
the damages uh to the other parties or
to prevent the contractor or business
relationship in other words generally
speaking anyone can interfere with
someone else's contract you just can't
go about doing it illegally in the first
place now you might have noticed that
this lawsuit was filed in federal court
in Texas but you might not immediately
know why uh first year law students
learn all about the different ways a
court has personal and subject matter
jurisdiction and this takes weeks to
learn uh but here's a very fast rundown
personal jurisdiction is the Court's
ability to exercise jurisdiction over
the rights and responsibilities of a
person subject matter jurisdiction is
the requirement that a given Court has
the power to hear the specific kind of
claim that's being brought in that Court
federal courts have subject matter of
jurisdiction uh where there is a federal
question or where the plantiffs and
defendants are all domiciled in
different states now one form of subject
matter jurisdiction is called diversity
where parties are from different states
and here Twitter is a Nevada corporation
with his principal place of business in
California and Media Matters is a
Washington DC Corporation so the
elements of diversity seem to be met but
it doesn't appear that there's any
personal jurisdiction in Texas because
nothing appears to have happened in
Texas it's possible the courts might
exercise what's called long armed
jurisdiction here but basically because
nothing happened in Texas I would expect
a motion to dismiss to get it out of the
Texas Court in the first instance but
there are some very good reasons why
Elon Musk wants this case specifically
in Texas instead of California even in
federal court one reason is that this
case could eventually be heard by the
fifth Circuit Court of Appeals which has
issued some Bonkers opinions related to
free speech and social media companies
now some of the more student viewers
might be wondering whether Texas has an
anti-s slap law and the answer is they
actually do a pretty good one but as
some people may be shouting at the
screen right now uh one of the fifth
circuit's less Bonker decisions involves
the application of the Texas anti-s slap
laws uh basically the fifth circuit has
ruled that the state's anti-s slap laws
do not apply in federal court typically
when someone is sued for defamation or
something like defamation they can argue
that it's an attack on free speech and
get the lawsuit dismissed early in the
process that's the point of an anti-s
slap law but by filing the complaint in
Texas Federal Court musk ensured that
Media Matters would not be able to use
the state law and as I said Texas has a
pretty good anti- slap law the Texas
citizens participation Act was enacted
to deter meritless lawsuits it allows
defendant to file a motion to dismiss a
legal action that infringes on the
rights to free speech and a defamation
or disparagement uh lawsuit is the
classic kind of lawsuit that should get
dismissed by an anti-sap law this motion
can be filed early on in legal process
often before the case proceeds to
expensive and costly Discovery however
because Elon Musk filed in federal court
Media Matters will not be able to use
the tcpa to defend against the lawsuit
that's because the 2019 fifth circuit
ruling stated that that particular state
law doesn't apply in federal court
that's because the fifth circuit uh also
with a number of other Federal circuits
have decided that the state law is in
conflict with the federal rules of civil
procedure because the tcpa operates
without predecisional Discovery so Media
Matters will not be able to use the
anti-s slap law to fight this slap
lawsuit now Elon muskus said that he may
require Twitter users to provide
identification to verify their identity
which sounds horrible for several
reasons including because it's probably
only a matter of time before Twitter's
data is hacked which is why I use
today's sponsor incog incog removes your
personal data from online data Brokers
they'll reach out and make sure it's
taken down and if these data Brokers
object which I've personally seen incog
will take care of that too now I don't
know if you've ever Googled yourself but
there are major people search sites out
there that probably already have your
personal contact info it might be
because of a data hack but sometimes our
friends and family even provide that
information voluntarily by clicking on
one of those boxes when they sign up for
a website or an app these sites provide
in-depth records including information
such as home addresses contact details
license plate numbers family members
financial information even religious and
political beliefs and these sites can
expose you to a wide range of dangers
from scams to identity theft to online
harassment and stalking now it was very
important to me that I not be on those
sites and incog took that information
down and not only does incog stop
marketing efforts but it also reduces
the risk of your information being part
of a data breach or abuse an identity
theft or stalking that you really don't
want to take a chance with now now I'm
constantly getting notifications that my
information and account info was found
in part of a data breach but incog
fights for you to have your personal
data taken down from data Brokers data
Brokers are required to remove your
personal information from their
databases if you ask them to but
tackling this by yourself would be
nearly impossible because there's
thousands of them but that's where incog
comes in incog fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from data
Brokers and deals with any objections on
their side all you have to do is create
an account and give them approval to
work on your behalf incog conducts
repeated ongoing removals because even
if the data broker removes your data
once they can collect it again incog Mak
sure that your personal information
stays off the market for good it was
fascinating for me to look at my
incognit dashboard and realize that I'm
on hundreds of data Brokers lists so I
guess it was no surprise why my email
box was full of junk and my phone was
constantly ringing with scam calls
here's my personal incog dashboard it
shows here that there are three sites
that had data on me that was rated 10
out of 10 on incog sensitivity scale
these Brokers had data including my
contacts financial data and health data
and it's terrifying to see exactly how
many Brokers have my data but it's
really fun to watch incog get them to
delete that info one by one so if online
privacy is important to you give incog a
try click on the link below to get 60%
off incog when you use the code legal
eagle again to get an exclusive 60% off
discount just click on the link that's
on screen or down below in the
description and use the code legal eagle
at checkout and after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court